it's meant to level the playing field
for students who have difficulties like
anxiety and other things but a new
report shows the number of students
getting special allowances for extra
time on the SATs has surged recently and
on the heels of the operation varsity
blues admission scandal is this just
another test taking advantage here to
react is Michael Knowles the host of the
Michael Noel's show hey Michael good to
see you good to see you what do you
think about this or all these kids that
are getting this special it's called a
504 designation are they deserving of it
I'm kicking myself because I think I'm
the last guy in the country who actually
took the SAT in the amount of time
you're supposed to and who didn't bribe
coaches to get into college I don't look
like a football player so maybe that's
why the issue here is not students who
do need extra time because they have
learning disabilities the issue is all
of the other kids who are pretending to
have learning disabilities to cheat the
system the SAT historically was the only
standardized measure to get into college
you have a ton of other factors to
consider race legacy athletics all of
these others you have one standardized
measurement now that has been destroyed
and it's not only destroyed by the
students who are cheating on the test
it's being destroyed by the SAT itself
the SAT is now adding a new adversity
score which is purporting to measure
students individual suffering how
they're going to do that I'm not exactly
sure the broader cultural problem is
that we have transformed from a society
that rewards real accomplishment into a
society that values victimhood and so
ironically now if you can show that you
have some victimhood or you can pretend
to be an aggrieved victim ironically
that has become a privilege great well
the pretending part bothers me I mean
I've one of my children wound up getting
extra time because they have a learning
difference at an IEP and in fact it was
the teachers who said you know you
should wind up with extra time for the
SAT because of a visual problem couldn't
really see the test very well but if
you're suggesting that some parents or
teachers are trying to give the kid
extra time and and claiming they're a
victim and they're not really that's
that's a problem well now in certain
settings you have as many as been a
victim sorry in certain schools you have
as many as one in four students who were
getting extra time on this test I don't
think one in four students actually has
a learning disability we have this
allowance for the exam because certain
students really do need it they really
are at a disadvantage but what you have
now is a culture which is at the
personal level at the parental level
students who are willing to cheat and
parents who should know better or
encouraging them to cheat and why is
that it's because unfortunately the
educational value of a college degree
has plummeted study after study shows
that students aren't learning very much
in some cases they're graduating at some
of the top schools more ignorant than
they were when they came in but the
social value of a college degree has
skyrocketed MarketWatch shows that nine
out of ten new jobs are going to college
graduates but what does that college
degree mean what does that SAT score
actually mean it's in many ways an empty
signal but it's a credential that is
increasingly valued in our society yeah
a lot of times according to this study
you can see in the wealthier schools the
numbers are higher for the kids getting
this designation then then the the ones
with the lower socioeconomic
neighborhoods and more kids are getting
free lunch is that because these poor
families don't have the resources or
don't even know that they can ask to get
this designation there have always been
ways to game the system we saw that with
the last college scandal we see that
when people donate a building or make a
rightly time donation around College
Admissions but the people who get hurt
are the people who can't afford it the
people who get hurt or at the lower end
of the socio-economic spectrum and in
this case the people who are hurt are
the people who legitimately have
learning disabilities when there is an a
privilege that has opened up for certain
people it can be abused and in this case
it's being encouraged to be abused
because there is no more objective
standard in the system all right Michael
lols thank you very much for joining us
and congratulations on that SAT score by
the way
ironically 800 math 800 verbal and then
on the writing section was the section
at that time they had a writing section
he was the one I didn't get a perfect
score and then I went on to write a
blank book so I guess it makes sense
thank you very much Michael